*BUuurPPP*
HEEEEEEYYYYYYYY
Constantly people ask me
"What is your favorite game?"
And I always reply
*windows noises*
Honey pop
(Mad World - Gary Jules & Michael Andrews)
♫ And I find it kind of funny ♫
♫ I find it kind of sad ♫
It really offends me when people
say my girlfriend is Marzia
cuz my girlfriend is obviously
...
TIFFANY
(Hi There)
*kinda shocked poods*
*points to himself*
AREYOUTALKINGTOME?
(Ya you!)
*shocked*
HUUUHHHH
EUGHH
EHRG
I THINKIMINLOVE
(OooOoOkaaay)
I literally cant remember anything right now
(Riiiight...)
WHut
SHe's just goin'?!
She's just leavin??
*cri evrytiem*
I miss her so much ;-;
THUUUUU
S0-Sorry
Uhhh
just
uhhh
um... uhh
*pewds is speechless lol*
WAITAMINUTE
Who
Who ARE
Who ARE YOU!? *kazzo intensifies*
(dont you recognize this ADDDORABLE faceu?) *pewds is a weeb loser*
(giggles its key-)
OHGGGHHH
(-on the bar)
Of course I recognize
dat bourfita?
This is the best game
of all time
[R.I.P. Headphone users]
Okay, where are we now?
O my God it's Candy Crush
(alright, I'll try to make this quick)
Some brilliant man out there was like
*burpie*
''Hey Candy Crush is a pretty good game...
but wouldn't it be better if we added anime boobs?''
Ghawd Damn genius
hEY, UNDErTALE, IT'S A PRETTY GOOD GAME!
but Wouldn't It Be bEtTer with anime titties?
*undertale intro*
*blue screen*
*tiddies*
if only life was this easy
All you had to do is play candy crush, and you get bitches
Y'know this game really is a dream comin' true
I think for all of us.
And i think i speak for the entirety of mankind when I say that
It's such a good game, I'll never get tired of it
Almost there, almost at the climax baby
here we go
SUCCess ;)
.
..
...
That's what it says in real life as well
yAS
we did it
(see, i knew you had it in ya)
awight, where should we go first to hit up those sexy ladies?
Bros, leave a comment down right now, and I will pick whatever comment that gets the most-
Fitness club!  Let's go to fitness club!  (Game: Good choice rookie!)
*pewds falls in love*
TIFFANYY!
(Game: ...lit class was canceled.  Trying to make good use of the time.)  MAIN BITCH!
Fuck yeah!
(Other one: Hey, listen.)
Hell yeah!
[assorted grunts and belches]
(Game: Is this chick serious?  That schoolgirl uniform is a little on the nose, don'tcha think?)
Don't judge my girl Tiffany!  Shut the fudge up!
Ok, c'mon, alright, ehh heh!
Heh!  aheh! hae hehe aheh
(hah hah hah)
eheh (haw) eheh (haw) eheh (ha)
[distorted eheh]
Ok
"Hey, don't take this the wrong way, but I just thought you were cute and I HAAD TO SAY HI!!"
No, you stop it
alright
This is how you do it
This is how you do it (x2)
Oh the pleasure
I'm a cool -
I'm real cool, Im real cool
let's talk to her!
*pff*
wat
Okay, so she's a pure girl
uhhh
nevermind?
WhAt?
What was the right answer to that?
Fuck, we can't fuck up anymore
uhhhhhhhh
AnYwAy, wuts your breast size?
*laughs*
how old r u
*pewds imitates her*
okay... uuhh lets talk to her one more time
*laughs* you literally ju- you literally ju- HA
*imitates her* HI my name is Tiffany
QUIZ TIME!
Wut is my name?
EUHA
(ha ha ha ha)
EUHA 20 years old
*cooly* i know
You know, I pay attention to detail
I care about women
As I am NOT
a mysoginetics
Oh, bitch is hungry, I forgot, you have to,
like, buy them food & shit
Alright, so...
Purchase gift. Alright, so
we should buy tennis balls
No, uh
she's hungry, okay, food.
Would you like ... a wedding cake?
Do you like a Sundae?
WHY
Would you like a fruit?
MOTHER FUCKER
HAVE A CHEWING GUM
YES!!
She can't help herself
We are going on a date!
Hell yeah
HELL YEAH
We're going date,
We're going date!
We're going date, with Tiffany
We're going date -
OH!
BLAUGH
AUGH
AURRR
ERRR
EERRR
*Cough* *Cough*
[Drinking canned beverage loudly]
AUGHAAAH
Okay, here we go
yeah, you like that, girl?
Hell yeah
He- oh
OH OH OH OH OH
O-OH!
OOOOOOOH
HOO-HOO!
YES!
That's how you do it, bros
That's how you get a lady
Would you like an orange?
MUTHA FUCKA
Alright, we're just gonna have to
spend all our money on Tiffany
She's our main bitch, and that's what we're going for
You gotta single in
We're going all in on this girl
Would you like a tissue?
nope
Hey girl, would you like a muffin?
SO good
So good
How tall are you?
Five foot four, 5"4'
Remember this
remember dis
Okay, alright, some candy?
Would you want some pancakes?
oh my god sh-
She loves pancakes, everyone
Okay, she wants a lemon drop
Would you like a lemon drop?
That's not weird for anyone to give -
Hey (aha), here's a
lemon drop
it's your (a-ha)
favorite drink
would you like
would you like a lemon drop?
at school?
I made it for you, Tiffany
oh
ok then
When's your birthday?
December 22nd
December Twenty-Second
Dec. 22nd
December twenty-se-
Remember
REMEMBER
Was yo last name?
Tiffany Maye
Oh shit, oh shit, oh ...
oh shit, oh shit, please ...
please, i don't ...
YES!
'Most guys' Hahaha
Not me-a
aha
Aha!
(ha ha ha)
"I wasted my first kiss on my -"
What the fuck does that mean?
Our second date, I see
Don't fuck this up, Felix
The passion level is maxed out
I repeat, the passion level ... is maxed out
Come on, come on, this could be it
NOOOOO!
It's the WORST game
This game don't understand me
Stupid game
Stupid girls
I hate girls
They're the dumbest
Dumb girls!
EEERGH
If you're a girl, unsubscribe now
RRGH
Now I am a real
MYSOGENETICS!
So you better watch out!
Anyway
check out another video similar to this one
let me know if you want me to do another part of this
I would love to play more
Leave a like if you enjoyed
And as always
Stay awesome
BROS!
Hey, but bros only!